[Music]
today's question comes from sean in
mississippi he says my wife and i have
been tackling our two hundred thousand
dollars of debt for the past three years
and we have about 55k left
we've continued to tithe and contribute
to various christian organizations this
has caused some debate between us
i'm more aligned with taking a step back
from tithing and paying off our debt
however my wife remains steadfast in our
need to continue to tithe at least 10
percent of our income i know the baby
steps say that we need to complete baby
step two before starting baby step seven
however our charitable contributions are
very important to us if we had not
donated over the past three years we
would be debt free now do you have any
recommendations on how to persuade my
wife to concentrate solely on paying
down debt
wow
well that's assuming that we agree with
you sean isn't it
that's a problem yeah i think we're the
problem is we're probably not going to
agree with either one of you here
yeah sean is looking at the math and
going well if we stop tithing we could
pay off debt faster doesn't that make
sense dave that's the whole point of the
process
but it's not there's a heavy spiritual
component if you're a person of faith
that you should tithe 10 and that's the
baseline yeah and scripture is pretty
clear that it's first fruits
the tithe the 10 to your local church is
first fruits it comes off the top before
you do anything else
now uh we're not legalistic about it
that's just what the bible says
and so if you want to do something else
god's not going to be mad at you but his
instruction manual is very clear
that a tenth of your income goes to your
local church
this is what evangelicals have taught
and believed for years now lots of
people
have different you know viewpoints or
whatever within different denominational
movements but evangelicals
across the board this is what we teach
what we believe and there's a lot of
scriptural basis for it obviously and so
uh but again nothing has to do with your
salvation
god doesn't need your money the church
didn't really need your money if they do
they got other issues but real really
this is about you having a rhythm of
giving in your life and that god wants
you to have giving at the top of your
list always
so now where i would disagree with your
wife
is the other things that are not a tenth
of your income going to your local
church are not tithing the extra to
those called offerings
those are called offerings
and there is no scriptural indication
that offerings come from anything but
surplus and while you have debt you
don't have surplus
so offering should come from surplus so
i personally
did and would recommend that while
you're getting out of debt you tithe and
nothing more
and so i did not give to any other
ministries any other para church
organizations or anything else while i
was getting out of debt except my local
church my tenth you'll have plenty of
time to do that later once you're out of
debt but you're taking care of your own
household first you don't have surplus
and offerings come
from
surplus
and so even extra things that the church
is asking for we're in a building
program we're trying to raise money for
uh
whatever cause that the church is doing
well that they're gonna take it out of
my tithe check
um and that's what i did while i was
doing it
again none of this though is a salvation
issue none of this makes god love you
more or less
none of this falls in that bucket but
these are just the what if you do a
detailed in-depth bible study this is
where it will lead you and that's why
it's what we've done and what we've told
you to do now where would you say to
bring those back in the offerings the
charitable contributions would that come
after baby step three yes because we're
kind of done with the gazelle intensity
we're moving to intentional because baby
step three as far as i'm concerned is
taking care of your own household if you
don't have an emergency fund and you're
not debt-free you haven't taken care of
your rocky foundation and your scripture
says take care of your own household
first
or you're worse than an unbeliever okay
so take care of your own household first
and that doesn't mean be selfish as a
course of your life or as a character
quality it just means that you've got a
you know you got to feed your kids
before you feed hungry kids
because yours are hungry too okay and so
that's all that means you pay your light
bill before you pay the light bill at
the homeless shelter
and so you can let that fuel you i mean
if you're on the debt-free journey
absolutely it should fuel you they're
passionate if you have a desire about
giving it it means you're going to pro
that's high correlation between that and
people to build wealth let's get out of
that faster so that we can do what we
really want to do exactly which is give
outrages and the most fun you'll ever
have with money we teach on generosity a
lot we believe in generosity
but uh but that's the nuanced detail of
how to flesh out your generosity so your
wife is trying to do too much you all
have been doing too much and you're
trying to do too little so you both are
wrong what the difference that's
according to what we teach and according
to what i believe so there we go